tik tok c'est le réseau préféré des
années sans la majorité en moins de 15
ans on parle de dérives pornographiques
on parle de raquette on parle d'abus
bref ça a l'air d'être un sacré foutoir
ont pas se mentir petit récap on en
parle juste après à chaque âge son
réseau social si les plus âgés se
retrouvent davantage sur facebook les
plus jeunes sont quant à eux sur
snapfish ou instagram dimanche c'est
l'émission 7 à 8 qui s'intéressait à tik
tok un réseau de vidéo basé sur la
musique qui inquiète sur son contenu
s'est adressée aux enfants et aux jeunes
adolescents cette application a pour but
de publier des vidéos amusantes de
playback dans ses autres mini clips sur
des titres du moment
sauf que voilà entre le concept de base
et l'utilisation que certains en font
aujourd'hui il ya un véritable gouffre
en effet selon de nombreux observateurs
cette application est à l'origine de
nombreuses dérives m'a demandé de lui
envoyer des news ou des photos mais sans
cesse notamment sur le rapport au corps
car cette application valorise la nudité
et le physique parfait une image
déformée qui selon le youtuber le roi
des rats pouce de jeunes adolescents à
s'exhiber de façon dérangeante mais
nombre d'adolescents qui ont même pas
l'âge d'aller au collège qui font des
vidéos en brassière petite culotte
courir quand en faisant des danses sexy
dance du vent tout ça pour imiter celle
qui ont des centaines de milliers de
jeunes sur tik tok accusé de valoriser
la pornographie infantile par les défis
parfois tendancieux
la plateforme est aussi épinglée sur le
fait qu'elles collectent des
informations personnelles sur des
mineurs dont elles se servent ensuite
commercialement un espionnage dénoncé
par les états unis qui souhaitent
aujourd'hui interdire cette application
alors tik tok
faut-il s'inquiéter des dérives
alors c'est un sujet d'actualité tout le
monde en parle tous les concernés parce
que tout le monde et sur les réseaux
sociaux alors qu'on sait des grandes
personnes au mas poids sont des remparts
consentante
les adolescents les enfants sans plus
compliqué d'autant que techtoc est
vraiment dédié aux enfants
jean-louis là je pense qu'il faut
s'inquiéter comme tous les réseaux
sociaux mais je pense que la priorité là
dessus c'est d'abord d'éduquer nos
enfants à la de leur faire comprendre
des choses moi je vois que notre fille y
aller à fond là dessus mais on lui parle
avant on essaie d'avoir un contrôle
aussi sur son portable etc
mais je pense qu il faut s'inquiéter des
dérives de tous les réseaux sociaux mais
je pense qu'il faut d'abord essayer
d'éduquer nos enfants du mieux que
possible pour qu'ils sachent que voilà
ça peut être risqué et on voit dans
l'exemple ils disent des milliers de
jeunes veulent faire comme les personnes
qu'elles suivent sur instagram etc et
c'est un peu ce qu'on disait aussi sur
nabila il faut aussi que les autres
mettre un exemple c'est un peu compliqué
donc je pense que la chose a pu sommes
déjà c'est d'éduquer nos enfants et leur
dire attention à bien sûr vous comment
on peut faire puisque un enfant
maintenant il faut quoi à 12 ans il est
un portable wii modèle oui moi la fia de
l'année à l'internât à 12 ans il est
donné dans son portable il a accès à
beaucoup de choses il a accès alors que
papa des sites qui sont d'une simplicité
prouver ce qu'on fait on se met à table
en discutant famille et on essaye si
elle parle pas avec le papa parce que
des fois c'est peu plus difficile avec
un père et bien discute moi c'est sa
belle mère puisque j'ai refait ma vie
mais on discute avec console oui oui
j'ai eu une vie afin comme toi non
vraiment ça mais c'est sérieux pas une
mentalité des enfants qui ont des arts
est ce important
je te taquine et coûterait ailleurs mais
il faut tu le sais je pense qu'il faut
parler avec les enfants c'est d'abord la
chose la plus importante est de les
comprendre et qui nous comprennent aussi
caroline ithurbide ben oui ça remet les
parents au coeur d'un dispositif moi
j'ai une fille de 9 ans elle me parle de
tik tok elle mais elle veut acheter des
fringues des petite brassière des petits
cropped top des petits machins sa copine
aussi et c'est vrai que je suis obligé
d'avoir des conversations avec elle et
c'est pas le cas donc fils qui a douze
ans que je pense que c'est vraiment un
réseau social qui touche à énormément
les filles n'entend donc à moi je suis
pas confiant aussi par ça chez moi à ce
personnel mais ça remet obligatoirement
les parents au coeur du dispositif en ça
moi je connais très bien mais qu'est ce
que vous lui il ya ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement ce que pour en pas par an
pour pour adam en empêcher mais pour
limiter pour il n'ya pas des trucs
numérique a fermé il ya plein de
contrôles parentaux mois
pas de portable par exemple et monfils
caractères un portable la plainte
contrôles parentaux qui sont possibles
avec des limitations des restrictions
sur lequel on sur lesquels on peut agir
sur ça peut être le temps tu appelles la
quantité de de temps passé sur internet
etc
après non c'est vrai que moi je suis un
peu la nasse je suis un peu la mère earl
où on est dans une sorte de groupe de
mamans et on s'envoie toutes les
informations attentes a vu lui l'a fait
si lui l'a dit ça il faut parler à
marcher il faut parler à bidule donc on
est un peu un groupe 4 5 mamans
ah ouais ouais legault ben ouais mais je
m'en fous je préfère être le bang des
poux cave je préfère savoir moi c'est
vrai que de temps en temps je prends le
téléphone de mon fils et je regarde ce
qu'il écrit c'est un des trucs chelous
fmi attend gaspard tu viens ici et puis
je préviens toutes les autres mamans
naturellement au final elles sont quand
même tenté pas mal le gang
c'est une bonne idée #bastarache rejoint
un peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure
par rapport puisque dans le sujet ils
ont clôturé un peu avec ça en disant
comme quoi il voulait avoir des habits
comme comme des gens suivi que c'était à
sarah joue un petit peu ce que je disais
tout à l'heure par rapport à l'école
c'est sont les réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de 2,2 de grosses stars entre
guillemets des femmes comme hommes et en
gros ils se réfèrent beaucoup à ces gens
là mais savent que faut savoir c'est que
les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs j'ai
regardé un reportage qui est sur une
plate forme là qui est entré en ce
moment et il parle des réseaux sociaux
et les réseaux se sont fait pour
détruire les gens fait même mois pour
moi un enfant de 10 12 13 15 ans il n'a
rien à faire sur des réseaux sociaux en
fait les cra même manque l'époque où on
allait on jouer à la marelle avec son
vrai que je vais bien évidemment s'ouvre
ex longtemps mais c'est que sont les
réseaux sociaux il ya de tout et
n'importe quoi on voit des gens coûte
quitte werc on voit des gens qui se
foutent à poil
on voit des meufs schéma des lettres
chez valeur mais celui-là mais c'est
vrai non mais c'est même pas ça c'est
que en fait on voit tout et n'importe
quoi donc un enfant aujourd'hui la porte
et ils veulent allume son téléphone il
peut aller sur tout et n'importe quoi
oui et aujourd'hui ils grandissent avec
sa donc forcément quand ils vont à
l'école
est ce que tu as vu la vidéo de l'autre
at à vue l'auteur des tubes de
surprenant confinement il y avait des
live où il y avait des gens qui tout est
ok ah c'est sûr un télégramme sur un
style avait y avait il y avait des lives
de ça donc c'est très dangereux en fait
alors que cat et avoue forcément les
réseaux c'est un moins de communication
important pour nous
vous en servez quasiment tout le temps
oui tout le temps alors nous naissions
là aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
émettre des contrôles et encore une fois
je vous rejoins les enfants il faut les
éduquer ou les rééduquer leur faire
comprendre que les réseaux sociaux avec
tout ce qui est télé réalité qu stress
est un monde à part un monde fictif
c'est une bulle on ne peut pas elles ne
peuvent les enfants ne peuvent pas
s'identifier à ce à l'école on y va on
est là pour apprendre
or donc on doit s'habiller correctement
après on sort ça c'est encore autre
chose ça n'a rien à voir avec le droit
de la femme et la liberté de la femme la
liberté vestimentaire mais il faut en
permanence aujourd'hui parce que
l'époque si ça et vous avez raison de
souligner aujourd'hui il faut être en
permanence sur la rééducation
l'éducation des enfants et oui leur
expliquer que ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux n'est pas la réalité de
la vie portée des crocs top ça n'est pas
comme ça que l'on sort dans la rue